you guys know i like to end this show
and especially end the week on a
somewhat positive note and i think
people are just waking up in droves to
this thing it's becoming increasingly
obvious you can even see the media is
having trouble running cover for biden i
think they're done with him anyway
i don't think this kobe thing helps his
case uh but here's video a year ago uh
him and uh let's just call this uh
pandering 101.
it's awful hard as well
to get
latinx vaccinated as well why
they're worried that they'll be
vaccinated and deported
libby uh many latino people those tacos
as we refer to them as unique as the
breakfast tacos here in san antonio
uh they uh love being called latin x
right and uh they're all obviously
illegal which is why they would be
worried that they might get booted if
they got vaxxed i mean do they realize
their own racism
they do not realize their own racism
they think they're immune to it they
think that when they talk down to
minorities that is actually lifting them
up they think that when they pander to
you know woke ideology and and and say
these kinds of things that they are
actually helping the communities that
they are substantially attacking but
americans are way too smart for this
nonsense um and they were too smart for
it all along and we're you know we're
watching the the chips come in on that
one